Через два роки поряд зі старим леверкузенським мостом,
якому більше півстоліття, має з'явитися новий.
Через його аварійність на магістралі працюють
спеціальні системи контролю - так звані пастки для фур.
Якщо водій не помітив чи проігнорував знак заборони в'їзду,
його рух перекривають шлагбауми.
Ширина автомобіля не повинна перевищувати 2 метрів 30 сантиметрів,
максимальна вага - 3,5 тонни. На пункті контролю
постійно чергує співробітник, який стежить за моніторами.
- Щодня зупиняють близько сотні вантажівок перед мостом.
За нашими підрахунками, за період із кінця 2016 року,
коли ми встановили цю загороджувальну систему,
зупинили близько 60 тисяч вантажних автомобілів.
Таким чином захищаємо споруду до того моменту,
поки не завершимо новий міст.
Якщо вантажівка потрапляє в пастку зі шлагбаумів, -
штраф 500 євро і 2  місяці позбавлення водійських прав.
А як діють, коли вантажівка просто прориває огорожу та їде собі далі?
Таких випадків останнім часом нарахували близько 40.
Одного з порушників - водія з Іспанії, - наздогнали
через декілька десятків кілометрів від мосту.
На такий екстрений випадок на посту контролю
завжди є запасні шлагбауми.
Щодня міст в землі Північний-Рейн Вестфалія
переїжджають близько 100 000 автомобілів.
Це регіон із активним автомобільним рухом.
10 тисяч фур мусять щодня об'їжджати цей міст.
Водії вже давно на це скаржаться.
- Це катастрофа.
Додаткові витрати лише на пальне - близько 200 євро на день.
Через об'їзд мої автомобілі загалом проїжджають
на 600 кілометрів більше, ніж мали б.
Загалом біля мосту працюють п'ять пунктів контролю вантажівок.
Схожі системи встановлені ще на декількох проблемних мостах ФРН.